[Music]
hi I'm Rachel I'm a software engineer on
firebase security rules and I'm
Sebastian and I work on firestore Rachel
do you still remember what happened last
May how could I forget that was the
month that I was flooded with emails
from every website I had ever signed up
for I looked at that flood and I
wondered why I ever signed up for so
many things last May the general data
protections regulations took effect this
legally this legislation touches on
pretty much every aspect of user data
collection among other things it
regulates how app developers able to use
collect and store user data it was one
of the biggest changes to user privacy
that happened in a while but the basics
of user privacy remained the same if
you're building an app that handles user
data user privacy should be one of your
top concerns today Rachel and I will
show you some of the tools that we have
built at firebase to help you respect
you users data since neither of us are
lawyers
we cannot give you legal advice instead
we're going to treat user privacy like
software developers and stick to know
what stick to what we know best as
engineers we will tell you how firebase
can help you with your users privacy and
share our personal suggestions along the
way by not just focusing on gdpr
we hope that what you will learn today
will be applicable to all of you users
after all user privacy is larger than
any one piece of legislation even before
last may different regulations around
user privacy apply to users in most
countries Rachel I don't know what the
future of data privacy will look like
instead we will talk about the firebase
tools and principles that you can
already use today to build products that
put your users in control
but first let us explain what firebase
is we built firebase so that app
developers can focus on the features
that make their app unique we don't want
you to have to spend your time spinning
up a back-end service just so that you
can store a bit of data firebase takes
mundane tasks out of building an app we
want to be with you from your very first
line of code until you reach planet
scale maybe you've heard of firebase
before it's okay if you haven't we
shipped our first product in 2012 the
firebase real-time database since then
we've been growing our offerings and
have been watching what customers are
doing with our products in 2016 we
introduced the firebase SDKs for cloud
storage cloud storage for firebase
allows you to build apps that let you
user securely up and download files from
Google's cloud be gracefully handle poor
network connectivity
and use cloud storages X caching to
offer superior performance and in 2017
we introduced cloud functions for
firebase cloud functions for firebase
allows you to run your own server side
code without forcing you to set up your
own servers cloud function uses
event-driven lightweight JavaScript that
runs when data on the backend changes
and just last year we launched cloud
fire store cloud fire store is a
scalable database for mobile web and
server development we offer feature-rich
SDKs that integrate directly with the
firebase platform our SDKs support
direct for mobile access and allow you
to write customer facing apps without
the need for application servers today
firebase offers 17 products that help
you develop grow and earn from your
mobile apps
all of our products are built around one
core principle we want you to build apps
with rich becket integrations without
having to set up these backends yourself
we're in the business of storing data so
naturally we've put a lot of thought
into a question that you or your CIO
might have asked recently why do we how
do we handle those privacy requirements
when we're building cyrillus apps user
privacy was traditionally not a concern
for developers when they were evaluating
cyrillus backends the questions that you
would use when you're evaluating service
products were things like what features
to this platform offer how will they how
will the parts of this interact together
and how well will each component scale
up for me by contrast the concerns that
you have when you're thinking about user
privacy are pretty different those are
things like how will I make sure that my
data is securely stored how I make sure
that my users understand the data that
I'm collecting and how will I make sure
that I remove the data when I no longer
need it so it doesn't seem like there's
a lot of overlap between these two types
of questions some people have even
suggested that serverless architecture
and data privacy could even contradict
each other
seems like rachel is reading my mind or
like we were at the talk together but
let's be honest even though I deeply
care about user privacy I am not willing
to give up serverless development just
yet I don't want to go back to the days
of installing maintaining and upgrading
my very own my sequel instances just so
that my Android app can receive a single
push notification fortunately service
design patterns and user privacy can
often go hand in hand at firebase we are
proud to offer products and tools that
help you protect your users data not
because not despite but because of our
service offerings let's dive in and take
a look at a few examples
we'll start by showing you how you can
reduce the data that you're storing and
you can use firebase as cloud functions
to make sure that you're managing this
data well we'll show you examples of you
deletion and user data export clicker
Sebastian I will dive into how you can
use firebases security rules to limit
the access that people have to your data
and how you can also describe data
ownership and we'll discuss notifying
your users about the data that you are
collecting that includes covering the
storage retention policies for our
backends and we'll show you patterns for
how you can store those privacy
preferences once users have given them
to you and we'll end with some advanced
use cases like activity logs to track
changes to privacy settings right soon I
want you to want you to design your apps
for privacy from the very first line of
code the easiest way to do this is of
course to not store any data Sebastian
not store any data okay let's stay
realistic and only save the data that we
need for example let's say we have an
app and we want to make sure that our
users are European citizens over 18
instead of storing the users full
birthday and country of birth we only
need to store whether they meet our two
criteria as you design your app think
about what data you need for it to
function and what the amount of time is
that you need to store this data for
whoa not everyone is starting with a
brand new project so if you have an
existing project you're not out of luck
let's look at some privacy features that
we've added to an existing app that we
call friendly picks friendly picks is a
reference implementation for many
different features implemented on
firebase and now it includes user
privacy features it has a
straightforward user facing feature set
it lets you it lets users sign-in upload
photos and then it has some social
features like commenting and favoriting
photos the data that's stored by
friendly picks all supports one of these
three features vApp store's account
information this is these are things
that are in addition to authentication
data that we get next friendly pics
stores the pictures that users have
uploaded a normal app might keep this
forever but for friendly pics because we
want to show lots of privacy features
delete all of the photos after one month
and finally friendly pic saves the
social interactions with these pictures
these are things like likes and comments
and we keep them until those things are
deleted by the users or until it's the
photo its associated with is deleted so
whether you're writing a new app or
you're improving the privacy of an
existing application the first step to
managing your privacy is to understand
exactly what data you're storing and the
features that that data is supporting
that will give you an idea of how long
you need to support it it gives you a
position to start scripting the data
removal once you no longer need it so
many organizations want to limit the
data they're storing and they only want
to keep the data they need and they only
want to keep it for as long as they need
it those are some principles to live by
and I want to stop here and acknowledge
that it isn't always as easy as you
might think to delete data you might
have a great engineering proposal for
how you're going to remove the data you
no longer need and that could meet with
a lot of resistance within the
organization maybe you have someone in
the org who hates the idea of data going
away for example you have an analytics
person that likes to run a query for how
many users between the ages of 18 and 25
are performing a particular action so
you can run that query if you know that
they're doing this and save that daily
count on the number of users and then
you can delete that the the data
associated with individual users that
way you keep your analytics person happy
and you also keep your users happy so
when you're auditing the data that you
need across your organization be as
specific as possible if you only need a
count of the number of users make sure
that you know that even if we store only
the minimum amount of data we should
still structure in it and structure it
in a way that makes it easy to delete it
later to me offering users the ability
to delete their own data is an important
pillar of user privacy you should delete
user data not only when a user requests
that their account is being removed but
also when you no longer need a specific
set of data for your app to function if
you design your app with user privacy in
mind deleting user data can be
pretty simple with firebase the a
synchronous nature of most elites makes
deleting a great use case for google
cloud functions a service that should
already be one of the primary tools in
your server list tool bells
well deletion is often triggered by
explicit actions in your app as in this
example of user deleting their post
remember that you ultimately don't
control the requests that come from your
client you don't want to rely solely on
your customers to clean up their own
data to remove data that is no longer
needed you can instead create a cloud
function that cleans up unneeded items
cloud functions for firebase are like
programmatic glue it lets you extend and
connect all of the firebase products and
all of the cloud products as well so you
can create a completely service back in
for your web and your mobile
applications cloud functions are
event-driven they're lightweight
JavaScript and this means that they are
deployed and this means that when
something happens it causes this
function to run that's the way to think
about it
so how do functions work all cloud
functions are triggered by some action
that is taken on your system this could
be something like an image is uploaded
or a user has clicked this button in
this case let's say we want to trigger a
function when a user logs in when that
event occurs an event is emitted in this
case from firebase authentication a new
event is a new environment is spun up
that only has my code and the
dependencies that I've declared for my
code then that code was in my function
is executed in this example say the user
when the user logs in my function will
create some default records for the user
in fire store as another example we need
to leet a document from fire store you
can trigger a custom function that can
clean up all that related data sometimes
it's obvious when data is obsolete in
Franti pics for example we delete all
comments and likes many user requests
that we delete a picture for other use
cases it's not as apparent if you app
has functionality that only temporarily
needs some of its data
I'd recommend deleting the unused items
when they are no longer needed an
example of a case where you only
temporarily need data is a high score
list in which you only need to keep the
highest scores and not the complete
history friendly pics really is a good
model here it doesn't keep any data
longer than 30 days and uses a clock
function to periodically delete all
their items you can find an article that
explains how to set up a cron job to
trigger a Tod function at the shortlink
or you can use the new cloud scheduler
to schedule functions to run
periodically you'll also ensure that you
know and keep any user data when users
delete their accounts if you're seeing
firebase authentication you can call the
delete API from the firebase user object
or to delete to delete all of that
information but calling delete will not
however remove user data that's stored
in other products for example firestore
if you're going surrealist that cleanup
is a great use case for firebase
functions the function could either be
triggered by an authentication delete
event or if you're not using firebase
authentication you can trigger the you
can trigger the function via an HTTP
request we've done some of the work to
get you started here by publishing a
general-purpose account deletion
function that you can tune to work with
exactly your data model so let's walk
through that quickly first this is my
function it lives in index J yes when a
user clicks the delete account button
that's going to call the delete API in
firebase authentication and that
triggers this function to run but my
code is generalized here to make it work
specifically for this one app I've
needed to add a JSON file called user
privacy JSON that lives in the functions
folder this file allows me to delete the
paths that need to be removed when a
user deletes their account I can find
the paths for all the services I can
define the paths for all the services
that I use such as fire store real time
database and storage and I'm using
variable here for the parts of the app
that will be replaced by the users ID
when the function is triggered I get the
UID from the event data object and
because I went to remove data from
firestore the real-time database and
storage I'm going to call three helper
functions if you're not using one of
these services you can easily exclude
that and not include that unused
function each of the helper functions
share the same basic structure but let's
walk through the function from the
real-time database as an example first
I'm going to fetch the relevant parts of
the the relevant paths from the JSON
file and then I'm going to iterate
through each one of those removing the
data at that path when each iteration
returns I'm going to return control to
the top-level function I throw it to you
you may also want to offer you users
data portability providing users a copy
of their data in a well-known and
machine readable format allows them to
transfer their data between different
service providers we've released another
cloud function called export data that
can help you with this the export data
function is triggered by an HTTP request
that you can make when you use a request
a copy of their data it calls three
helper functions that perform the export
for each product the upper function in
this case the one for the real-time
database use the same user privacy to
JSON file that Rachel just showed you
you can use the exact same configuration
or you can provide separate paths the
helper functions it's right through the
schema and export a JSON file that is
then uploaded to cloud storage it is
incredibly important that this exported
data in cloud storage is only accessible
to the user whose data you export it you
can accomplish this by using firebase
security rules the security model for
all of firebase is products since the
export data function uploads the
exported data to a location that
includes the user's user ID you can
create a security rule like this which
makes the data only
accessible to that user remember that it
is essential that you audit your
security rules if you're storing any
user data with firebase with firebase
security rules if you deny access in one
world's expression but grant access in
another we combine them and access is
granted make sure that you understand
that our rules are all together if you
have a more complicated data model that
can't be expressed as a list of wildcard
paths like the one we have in our JSON
file that's okay in that case I would
suggest that you maintain a list of
locations through the users data and you
can use that list as the input for a
similar cloud function that just like
this one iterates through those paths
and either deletes or copies that data
over depending on if you're doing an
export or a delete if you use data port
if you keep dated portability in mind as
you are building your app then deleting
an exporting data it can be as simple as
configuring one of these general-purpose
functions service development can
respect user privacy and make it easy
and we're making it easier than ever
with cloud functions for firebase you
can manage your users data without
building out expensive infrastructure
and we've published a guide for clearing
and removing users data you can find
more about it at this link let's recall
how security is handled in the
traditional back-end application in a
let's call it server full application
there's a client of storage layer and an
application layer the application layer
is often used to enforce security and
access controls if a client sends a
malicious request the application layer
can drop the request in server list
systems the application layer has been
removed the client connects directly to
the storage layer so we also the server
list system and force access controls in
firebase access controls are enforced
right at the storage layer we validate
everything
coming requests against the security
rules that you configured security rules
are your first line of defense in
creating secure firebase apps and secure
apps really are an essential part of
treating your users data well and
correctly configuring security rules is
an important step in preventing
unauthorized data access we've heard
from a lot of firebase users that
security rules can be intimidating or
even confusing so we've invested a lot
of time and energy and thought into
creating new products that make it
easier than ever
so because security rules are so
important we want to spend a little bit
time in this talk walking through some
of the new features that we've built
around security rules first before you
deploy your rules you can try them out
and play around with whether you might
want that to look like in the web
console there are simulators and they
let you test different types of requests
so you can say for this type of request
shouldn't succeed and then you can test
to make sure it succeeds for a different
type of request you can test that it
does fail just like you want it to you
can block access the simulators though
have a limitation they only help you as
you're writing the tests as you're
writing your security rules what happens
if last week sebastian wrote great
security rules and this week i came
around and tried to improve them and I
accidentally granted access to a lot of
people that I shouldn't have to make
sure that you can have confidence in
your rules going forward we now offer a
security rules emulator simulator an
emulator small difference in words big
difference in product and then and the
emulators run locally so it lets you run
that you can run this locally you can
write tests around what your rules do
and then you can include that as part of
your continuous integration workflow
there NPM tests you can include them
really easily in what you're already
running so check out the link for more
information
the security rules we've shown you today
describe a schema for your data and
spell out invariants for your back-end
they allow you to limit not only who can
access your data but also limit how the
data itself relates to one another
please remember to never trust the data
from your client apps since you no
longer have an application layer
security rules are the best way to
enforce access controls use the security
old simulator we offer in our firebase
web console to help you write and verify
your security rules and use the new
security security rules emulator to
create automatic tests around your rules
now we're ready to start informing our
users about the data that will be
collected at firebase we've published a
guide to our data retention on our
website and you can include this
information as you inform your users
about what you're doing with data
collection the firebase data privacy
terms also explain what kind of data
each firebase product collects how long
that data is retained and how you can
delete that data and we've also released
a white paper that explains what happens
inside of google cloud when you invoke
an API to delete data this is more for
your information if you're curious then
for your data collection policies but if
you'd like to see that it's available on
the website as well thank you
when you read our data privacy terms you
may see that some firebase products like
cloud messaging or a/b testing have the
ability to identify individual devices
this device level identification is done
via firebase instance IDs and it allows
us to message or change the experience
for only a subset or few users because
firebase instance IDs are so important
let's quickly go over them if you
incorporate a product that uses firebase
instance IDs firebase automatically
assigns a unique ID to each app
installation if you install two
different firebase apps on the same
device they each have a different
instance ID if you install the same app
on two different devices say an iPhone
and an iPad they will also have two
different instance IDs on the other hand
when you restart the same app on the
same device firebase keeps the same
intensity that's how we can send
notifications to apps even when they are
not open while instance ID data is
generally not meant to be personally
identifying it can potentially be linked
to any personal profile data that you
store in other products if you want to
allow your users to opt out of this type
of data collection you can disable
instance ID generation
we have also add a dedicated API star
admin SDKs that let you delete the
instance IDs themselves it is your
responsibility as a developer to invoke
this API so any user requests account
deletion
for firebase products that key data by
instance ID the time it takes to remove
this data varies per product and you can
find more information on this in our
privacy terms keep in mind that deleting
data from our back-end system does not
immediately delete all copies of that
data some of it lives in backup systems
and caches temporarily so you can think
you can look at the terms to understand
more about when it will be completely
delete
so now that we understand the data that
Google is saving entertaining and you
have in mind the data that you need to
support the features that you've written
let's talk about how to inform users and
give them all the information they need
to make a meaningful decision in
friendly pics we've added a notice to
let users know what kind of data is
being saved and what features that data
supports this notice gives them a choice
if they'd like us to save that data or
if they'd like to disable that feature
and features are only enabled for the
users that want that data saved they've
have to actively check to make sure that
that data will be saved for example if a
user doesn't want us to share their
social data we remove the ability to add
comments altogether if user doesn't want
us to store any data at all firestore a
friendly pic still has a really good
read-only mode depending on how much of
your app's functionality is handled by
our backends you may also need to
persist the users privacy settings in
firestore or in the real-time database
when you consider structuring this data
you should look at how it will be how it
will be read and what privacy controls
your back-end actually needs you'll
likely want to make sure that these
settings are stored in a place where you
can prevent unauthorized access by other
users for example if you use us profile
information this public
you probably want different access
restrictions to these privacy related
settings you can use layer you can use a
layout such as the one here which
contains a private profile section in
addition to a public one alternatively
you could store the privacy preferences
in a separate section of your database
altogether you also want to build a way
for users to update their privacy
settings this allows you to build new
features over time or to modify existing
features it's one thing however to let
people update their settings and it's
another thing to think through the
process of what you'll do with your data
when those settings change for example
say a user grants consent for us to save
their photos and then they change their
mind what should we do with the existing
photos that we've already saved this
balance between user expectations and
user privacy is different in every
application in fredley pics we decided
to keep the existing pictures that in
case the user wants to see those stilt
they can still delete them on their own
or will delete all of them when they
delete their account as users change
their consent settings you may also want
to keep a record of these changes in an
activity log an activity log allows you
to share security or privacy related
changes with your users and gives them
the ability to monitor changes to their
accounts if you're storing privacy
settings in firestore or in the
real-time database this is another good
case for Google Cloud functions with
cloud functions firebase can
automatically maintain an activity log
for you it's straightforward to create a
small function that is triggered every
time a user's privacy settings change
and which then copies the new settings
to an append-only storage location
here's an example of an activity logger
that listens to changes in the privacy
collection of fire stores and adds
entries to a dedicated activity log
collection if you want to make sure that
this activity lock is append-only and
cannot be modified you can use security
words to prevent any changes for example
if your activity log uses the firestore
collection for each user and a document
for each time a user changes their
settings you can use a rule like this
which allows document creation but
doesn't allow updates of existing data
we've created a guide to storing and
using privacy settings in firebase that
explains how to automatically maintain
activity logs you can find a link to it
on this slide or by or on the firebase
website so building privacy features
like secure access controls data
Portability and data cleanup can be with
an easy reach of every developer
service architectures many of the
privacy features that we've pointed out
today can be easily deployed to cloud
functions and we've shown how you can
lock down your data using firebase
security roles we hope that the tools
and technology we've highlighted can
help you turn user privacy into some of
the easiest features that you put on
your app gdpr is not the first and it
will certainly not be the last piece of
legislation that changes how we handle
user data the ever-growing list of user
privacy regulations can seem really
daunting and it makes touching any data
any kind of data really difficult but
let's all take a step back and let's
instead focus on doing the right thing
for our users if we treat our users data
with respect if you make sure our data
retention policies are easy to
understand if we limit the amount of
data that we handle and if we offer our
users the ability to make meaningful
decisions about the data that they lend
to us then we'll likely be in a good
place no matter what privacy regulations
the future may bring come find us later
at the firebase booth in the expo we'd
love to talk to you about how you can be
responsible with your users data
remember that we can't help you as
lawyers but we can help you as friends
[Music]